You. Hello and welcome.
It's active active inference GuestStream
number 42.1 on May 10,
2023. We're here with Juan Diego Bogota
and Zach Shabara. We're going to have a
presentation, Time Consciousness in
Computational Phenomenology a Temporal
Analysis of Active Inference by the
authors by followed by a discussion. So
thank you both very much for being here.
We'll look forward to your presentation
and off to you. Cool. Thank you.
So I should start now, right?
Brilliant. So hello, everybody. My name
is Juanito Bogota. I'm one of the co
authors of this paper. I'm a PhD student
at the University of Extra in the UK.
And kind of my broad interest are
philosophical phenomenology and how it
can be related to empirical sciences,
and more specifically to cognitive
science and to our understanding of
consciousness. So what we're going to do
now is I'm going to give a broad context
of our paper. I'm going to talk about
the theoretical and philosophical
context that motivated our paper. And
then Zach will talk about kind of the
specifics of our analysis of active
inference. So let me start now.
So to kind of situate ourselves in
the broader literature, I guess there's
a big, big cluster of discussions and
topics and approaches within cognitive
science and consciousness studies that,
as it names Sudest, is trying to explain
consciousness scientifically. Within
that kind of big category of approaches,
there's a very specific set which is
trying to connect philosophical
phenomenology with the natural sciences.
So we may call this the naturalization
of phenomenology. I'll talk about all
this in a bit. I just want to kind of
situate ourselves within the broader
context. One of these approaches is
quite popular in some circles, which is
called neurophenomenology and was first
introduced and proposed by Francisco in
the late 90s. But recently,
Barela's project has been kind of
elaborated on by people within the FEP
and activist community. And they're
talking about what is called
computational neurophenomenology or
computational phenomenology, which, as
we'll see, tries to connect the original
project of neurophenomenology of
bringing together cognitive science and
phenomenology. But it gives an active
inference twist to this whole story.
And this is where our project is
situated. Our main purpose in the paper
was to give a temporal analysis of the
structure of active inference, and in a
bit, I'll explain you why we thought
this was important. So, as you
probably know, consciousness is a
bit of a difficult phenomenon to explain
scientifically. We have nowadays a lot
of models and theories, scientific
theories, to try to address
consciousness. But there's always this
kind of lingering worry that there is a
gap, an explanatory gap between our
empirical understanding of the world
nature and consciousness, because how we
usually do science is try to address and
capture empirical phenomena from a third
person perspective, whereas
consciousness is something that is
allegedly given only from a first person
perspective. So we're always
experiencing the world from our first
person perspective. And allegedly, we
don't really have access to
consciousness as these empirical
phenomenon we can see in the world. So
that's kind of an epistemological gap
between how we do science and how we
understand consciousness without doing
much science. There's also the Soho
problem of consciousness, which is to
say that we don't really know how
something like consciousness may arise
from, say, neo biological phenomena or
empirical phenomena more generally. So
this is kind of a general context which
shows that consciousness is quite
difficult to understand. I don't think
we would want to say that it's
impossible to explain it from a
scientific perspective, but it's
somewhat difficult in the broader
context of consciousness studies. Since
the early 90s, there's been some
proposals within cognitive sciences,
cognitive science and philosophy of mind
is trying to connect this whole idea of
explaining consciousness scientifically
with what is known within philosophy as
phenomenology. So importantly here,
when we talk about phenomenology, we're
using a very specific and technical
term. So in the literature, you may
distinguish two different ways of
talking about phenomenology. There's the
usual broader sense in which we may mean
kind of the what it's like to experience
something or the qualitative contents of
experience. This is not what we're
talking about here. Rather, we're
referring to phenomenology, which is
very specific philosophical tradition,
which was first proposed by Ethan
Husserl in the early 20th century and
was further developed by people like
Morgan Merlot, Martin Heidegger, Simon
de Bois. And there's a long, long
tradition going on there. And what's
interesting about phenomenology is that
it's simply a philosophical method and
way of studying the invariant structures
of consciousness. So what all these
phenomenologists are trying to say is to
capture what they call the essential
kind of characteristics of what it's
like to be conscious of our lived
experience through which we experience
the world. We do this by describing and
analyzing precisely these experiences.
And you may think that this is pretty
much what kind of the broader sense of
phenomenologists trying to get to. So
this idea of what it's like to
experience something. But actually
phenomenologists are not really
interested in the what of experience.
They're not really interested in the
context of consciousness. So when
epenomologists talking about, say,
perceptual experience, they are not
really interested in the redness of the
red or the flavor of an apple,
what philosophers or qualia rather,
they're actually interested in how is it
possible that these experiences come to
be. So this how this refers to these
structures. We may talk about, for
example, the temporal structure of
consciousness. We may talk about
activity embodiment.
But the important thing here is that
we're focusing on the how we experience,
not what we experience. And that's very
important because at least how I see it,
I don't know about Zach. This how
actually constrains the what. So it's
very different to imagine an apple than
to experience it. So there's a
difference between the how we're
experiencing the world and that
constrains the specific contents of our
experience. And this is important for
the broader context of explaining
consciousness scientifically because
arguably, if we're focusing on the how,
we're trying to capture the essentials
of consciousness and this is a project
that was one of the kind of this project
was spearheaded by Franciscoarella in
the in the 90s. But we can actually
trace back this idea to the works of
Melaponte and Adam Hurvich in the
philosophical phenomenalogical
tradition. We can also talk about Hubert
Dreyfus. And more recently, there's a
kind of a very broad discussion about
whether and how can we connect these
philosophical considerations with
scientific perspectives of
consciousness. And this brings me to the
so called project of the naturalization
of an immunology.
We do science and world
through the lens, the natural side. We
have ethical understanding
of the world instead of metaphysical and
epistemological commitments such as
that. There is a material world out
there which you can get to know through
schematics or doing empirical tests.
That's how we find, very broadly
speaking. But when you go and look the
literature, the phenomenological
literature, what phenomenologists
provide are not causal explanations of
consciousness. They are simply
describing a set of what they call
motivational connections which not
really identify with causality,
which is the main thing that science is
trying to capture causal relationships.
Also, there's the issue that
phenomenology is not positing empirical
entities. So when we talk about, say,
unconsciousness, we're not talking about
empirical thing an empirical object,
arguably, we're talking about a set of
processes which and this is kind of the
shift from the scientific issues to
philosophical ones. We're talking about
something that is arguably prior to
objectivity. So phenomenologists are
often reminding the readers
that before we're doing science like
we're doing the theoretical science,
we're experiencing the world. And
therefore this is something that is
prior epistemologically to science. And
to try to capture consciousness
scientifically is almost to commit a
category mistake. So given these
worries, the question is whether we can
actually link phenomenology with
empirical science, such as cognitive
science. And this question is precisely
what we talk about, what we call the so
called project of naturalization of
phenomenology, which is to mean how are
we to make phenomenology continuous
with empirical science? There's a lot of
proposals in the literature. There is a
very important book published in 1999
edited by Dean Petitoat called
Naturalizing Phenomenology which the
editors and several authors discuss how
and whether we can actually naturalize
phenomenology. But one of the most
famous proposals is precisely Francisco
Varela's proposal of the naturalization
of phenomenology, which is called
neurophenomenology. So put very simply,
what neurophenomenology is all about is
to provide a non reductive approach to
the study of consciousness. This non
reductive approach takes seriously both
the analysis and descriptions made by
phenomenologists as well as the
scientific understanding we have of the
neurobiology that underpins our lived
experience these two kind of domains are
put in relation to one another by means
of what Valela calls reciprocal
constraints. So the idea is that
phenomenology can constrain our
understanding of the neurobiological
underpinnings, and these neurobiological
biological underpinnings can also
constrain our understanding of
experience, our phenomenological
understanding of experience.
Interestingly. And this is where kind of
the computational and mathematical
aspect comes in. Varela also suggested
that in order to achieve this
kind of circulation between
phenomenology and empirical science, we
have to have some sort of bridge or what
he calls a generative passage that
allows us to go from these very
abstract, phenomenological descriptions
of experience to the more concrete,
concrete descriptions of somatic and
neural processes that underpin lived
experience. And this very abstract level
that allows for this passage, for this
bridge, for him, for Valella, was the
use of dynamical systems theory and more
specifically, models of nonlinear
dynamics. So if you look at his 99
paper on time consciousness, what he
does is to connect Edmund Houstral's
analysis of temporality with certain
neural process by introducing
dynamical models into the picture. This
is what neurophenomenology is all about.
More recently, and inspired by this
whole project of neurophenomenology,
maxwell Ransted and colleagues have
proposed to further elaborate on this
project by employing generative modeling
techniques such as active inference to
provide this passage between
phenomenology and the neo biology. And
what is interesting about it is that if
you do so, if you introduce generative
modeling techniques, what you get is the
idea that this half of experience, how
experienced the world, or what
phenomenology is called constitution,
can be modeled or described in terms of
Bayesian imprints or approximate
Bayesian imprints. An important bit here
is that there's different ways of
interpret this. One way would be to say
that constitution or how we experience
the world is literally matter of patient
inference. Or there's a more kind of
instrumentalist or non realist
conception of this project in which you
would say we can actually just model or
describe our lived experience and how we
experience the world in terms of
approximated patient inference. In this
context, what happens is that the what
we experience in the world is
constituted through a set of inferences
which are informed by likelihood
mappings and all these matrices that
come in place into generative modeling.
So this is kind of a broader context
that informs our proposal. But you may
ask why we were focusing on time
consciousness. And I think Zach is going
to say something about it. But for now,
I just want to say that there's good
reasons, both phenomenological reasons
and scientific reasons, to apply
these kind of models to time
consciousness. On the one hand,
importantly, time consciousness is
simply what we mean by time
consciousness is our experience of time.
So how we subjectively experience the
passage of time and this phenomenon,
time consciousness enjoys a sort of
privileged position within philosophical
phenomenological literature. For
example, Husserl Heideggermer lebanti
are some prominent phenomenologists who
take time consciousness to be the most
basic structure of consciousness. The
point is that all that we're
experiencing all the time is always
experienced in time. There's always this
kind of temporal flow to the way we
experience the world, and this is kind
of essential to the way we engage with
the world. So if this is the most basic
structure of consciousness and we're
trying to understand consciousness
scientifically by modeling through,
say, genetic models or dynamical system
theory models, then probably we should
start by the most basic level, time
consciousness. And this is something
that several authors have actually tried
to do. So there's, for example, both Van
Gelders and Barela's dynamical models of
time consciousness, which borrow from
Edmund Husserl's phenomenological
analysis. There's also Gruce's
computational model of the same
processes. More recently, there's Vana
Visas predictive processing model of
time consciousness. So if you see,
there's also a relatively long tradition
of trying to capture the dynamics of
time consciousness in terms of
mathematical modeling. So now,
moving on to our temple analysis, our
main question is whether actually active
inference is capable of modeling these
dynamics in a way that
makes justice to the original
phenomenological analysis made out by
usro. And that's it for me. Now I'll
give the floor to Zach.
Here I am, and I hope you can hear me
and see me.
Yes, thanks. Share my screen.
All right, so going to pick up here from
where JD left, Juan Diego
left. And basically, like you said,
we started talking about, well, there
was this problem, right, with the flow
of experience and this discreteness in
which we we model, well, whatever
phenomena, really, especially in
cognitive science. So there is
this relationship and this claim that we
are in fact, modeling features of human
experience, like perception, memory and
so on. But it's very few, if any, of
them really take seriously the flow of
human experience. So phenomenology
is for philosophers and not for
scientists, apparently. So computational
phenomenology like JD just talked about
is like this new subfield that takes
both seriously, the computational
approaches, but also phenomenology, and
is trying to sort of find this middle
ground in which we can have a
conversation. And of course, big kudos
to Maxwell for this fantastic milestone.
I should say before I start that I'm
very happy that JD. Juan Diego is here
because I think that there is a lot of
thought and he has this very cautious
way of thinking and basically
formulating his sentences that I do not
have. So it's good that he's here. And I
should probably also say explicitly that
I will not be speaking for his behalf at
all. But we agree on basically all of
this. So just to be sure.
All right, so before I dive into the
whole temporality and active inference
aspect of our paper, I would just like
to start with a small thought
experiment. And I usually give this to
those who don't understand why I
personally think in time all the time.
So let's imagine that we have
to understand our own experience of
Space B. This is the Space B, this is
the Space A, this is Space C. So these
are all very, very different spaces,
right? And imagine there's two like a
parallel universe in the first universe.
In the first scenario, you approach
space B from Space A, right? So this is
you and you're basically moving in this
direction and you're experiencing this
space. Now in another universe, right?
Complete the fictional you're in this
person, you're this person and you're
approaching Space B. Now, I usually ask
my students, do you think that this
experience of Space B will be the same?
And usually they all go like, well, by
far the majority says no,
it's two very different experiences and
they have nothing to do with each other.
And this is basically what I'm sort of
asking people to sort of start thinking
about. There is no one to one isometric
relationship between space and
experience. And I think this is a very,
very important and very I wouldn't say
obvious, but to me it's very clear that
it cannot be like that. It cannot be
that one space or one specific type of
content will make me experience that
content the same way every time. And I
think that the reason for that is
change, right? Time dynamics,
everything changes. This is sort of what
brings me into this will bring us into
the discussion about substance
philosophy and process philosophy. I
will not unfold that at all, but I will
mention from time to time a few things
about them. So here I'm just going
trying to make the point that even like
intuitively, which is usually what we go
how we reason with these thought
experiments, it's basically why they're
here. It just appears to us that space
is not necessarily directly mapped to
an experience because we have to
consider time, right? So I'm asking
three questions here and the first one
will be how does the continuous flow in
human experience emerge? And I will try
to answer that through the differences
and similarities between what we call
objective and subjective time. I will
elaborate on that. Then I will try to
answer how we can we extract principles
from Husserlian temporalities Edmund
Hussarl that Fuentego just talked about.
And to answer that, I will talk a bit
about the enduring present and the
integration of two types of
temporalities that's the objective and
subjective one. And then finally, what
structured answer does active inference
comply with these principles? Sort of
using phenomenology to come up with
principle constraints and see whether
active inference is sort of playing by
those rules or not. And for that I will
try to give you our temporal analysis of
active inference as a partially
observable Markov decision process
computational model. So at Palm DP.
So first things first objective and
subjective time. So the objective time,
what do we mean by this? And I like to
think of them as roughly what
corresponds to substance and process
philosophy, respectively, because
objective time sort of deals with
spatial features and everything that is
rooted in the space. Whereas subjective
time, I like to think, has more to do
with how things change. So to give an
example, a substance philosopher would
say that the sun is simply the sun.
It's a thing and it's a sun, whereas a
process philosopher would say that, no,
it's a burning planet, it's doing
something. And so the river is not just
a river, it's running water. And you are
not you you're always changing and so
on. It's heraclitus all over. This is
basically the idea and the difference
between substance and process
philosophy. Now, if we project this
idea, like this abstract idea, onto the
discussion on the relationship between
objective and subject to time,
first of all, it's an important
discussion because computational models
operate on computers and these follow
the laws of physics, right? So we are
sort of bound by the laws of physics and
we sort of have to talk about objective
time in the context of the laws of
physics. So I like to think that in
space we can have several units at the
same time, right? You can count
different kinds of sheep. Like they
don't even have to look alike or
anything. I know that farmers can tell
the difference between the animals, but
maybe to someone who cannot, it will
just be like sheep one, sheep two,
sheep three, and so on. And you can then
even say a number, like you can go,
let's take a sheep number five. And you
will not even imply any other sheep
from, well, one to four. You don't imply
them at all, you just mean this one,
right? There's an identity versus
similarity discussion that needs to be
taken up then. So space allows us to
sort of categorize and discretize the
world. And I like to think about this as
the way that geometric series sort of
functions. We can take space and just
divide it infinitely. You can always
take anything and you can split it in
two, then in two again, then in two
again, and you essentially get what they
call the geometric series, which is
interestingly how you approach
continuous numbers and continuous
functions. Anyway, of course, I mean
this in theoretical terms because at
some point we're going to reach the
Planck length and then we're going to
have to deal with a different kind of
problem. But in any case, my point here
is that space allows us in the first
place to think in degrees, right? Like
there's a change in degree, how much
something is. But time, I think,
operates in a different way. Time sort
of has this single unit, right?
It's just a single kind as opposed to
the degrees. So there's a difference in
kind when we change moments, not a
change in degrees, which you will have
in space. So there cannot be any
division of time. This is why I usually
say that time for me is completely
indivisible. It doesn't make sense to
compare two different moments because
they have two different units and we
cannot compare them. So when I say that
we measure. Time.
I'm basically saying that whenever you
measure any time, you measure it the
same way. So when I say 5 seconds, I
imply all the seconds between zero and
five as opposed to to the space with the
sheep. So I guess you can also think
about the units of time.
I'm talking about the measure of time.
I think that sort of makes it easier to
understand. But because these
computational models, they are basically
operating with computers that are
operating with electricity and basically
the laws of physics, I think it's
important here to sort of think about
that in a broader term. And I here I
want to briefly quote Sir Arthur
Eddington who sort of is famous for
introducing the idea of the arrow of
time, stating that so far as physics is
concerned, times arrow is a property of
entropy alone. And I think that there
are some truth to that. So if we
consider the whole universe as a closed
system then we would expect the heat and
the energy to at some point even out
completely. Thermodynamically speaking
is the thermodynamic equilibrium and
this is where the entropy is highest.
So because the entropy of the system is
maximized or basically it's at its
highest value, it has reached a state
where all the possible ways of
distributing energy between the
particles has been completely exhausted.
Like there's no reason for any particle
to move anymore. There is no hot and
cold. Everything is the same
temperature. It's the maximum of
entropy.
I guess this is also why you sort of say
that energy is unavailable to perform
any work, right? So probably I should
also mention here that entropy actually
is a Greek word for transformation and
change. And I think this is exactly why
it fits very well with my understanding
of time here. It's the change, right?
It's the process. So entropy in an
abstract way, I think, sort of tries to
explain not only spatial states but also
spatial states in relation to time,
like how they can change.
So thermodynamically speaking, there
will always be a transfer from hot to
cold in order to reach maximum entropy,
to sort of create a balance. And
importantly, there is a linear causal
relationship, right? There's always like
one damn thing after the other, as the
saying goes. There's never anything
other than the linear way. And it goes
like the past causes the future and so
on. And of course, this is no consensus
about this. Lots of people in quantum
physics and quantum mechanics will
completely oppose that and think that it
actually goes the other way around. But
typically when we talk about this, at
least I believe in Newtonian physics,
there is a linear causal relationship.
So the features of objective time is
that it's spatial and that it's
temporarily linear. Now let's move on to
the subjective time. And as Juan Diego
already said, it's the A in the ABCs
of consciousness and subjectivity. So
going to give a brief demonstration of
how this particular diagram, which was
developed originally by Idmud Hussal in
his Bernard manuscript. Basically,
we have to think about the black line
here as the objective time, sort of,
right? One event, second event, third
and fourth and so on. And basically, if
we just take the present here as being
the event B, well, there is some kind of
expectation of what's going to happen at
the next moment that is affecting this
moment here. But not only that, there is
also another layer to that is going sort
of what we call a protention, right? A
protention of what's going to happen
even beyond C. And you can actually draw
this huge diagram out there and you will
eventually get a kind of protention
about the future. But at the same time,
we also have some information about
retention, right? There's something that
happened already and we are sort of
building our present moment based on our
retention. So the retention sort of
explains the immediate past and we do
not refer to this as memory or working
memory. It's very explicit that it's not
the same thing. I guess the one way we
can think about this is also in
terms of melodies, is what I'm trying to
say, and sentences. So, for example, my
sentence right now, I started it a few
moments ago, but it's still going and
you still have the full sentence in your
head and so on and so on. And basically
when we talk about the structure of
human experience and I think that Juan
Diego is absolutely right when he says
that for any unnaturalization project,
for it to succeed, it must at the very
least get the temporal order right. I
think this is like the basics of the
basics. So in this case,
the way that Edmund Hussal thinks about
it is that he thinks about it as the
living present being made of a synthesis
of retention and protention. And this is
what we call the primal impression.
It's the present moment. I will not
refer to it always as the primal
impression, but that is, I believe,
what you call in philosophy, the
technical term for living present.
But the main issue here still remains,
right? So how can what I'm writing here,
how can a sequential structure of time
be compatible with one that appears to
flow? This is the
issue that we are dealing with here.
And I think that there is two very
important principles that we can point
out from here. Brazilian synthesis that
any experienced moment in time cannot
consist of a discrete now moment alone,
but must instead coexist with the
immediate past and immediate future
which is basically the retention and the
protension in this case. But there is
also a very berksonian aspect to this
which is the interpenetration, right?
So the present moment requires the
coming together of subjective and
objective temporal structures, which is
exactly also what you see here. There is
an objective direction of time but
it's constituted by well past and future
all the time.
And this is basically, if we look at it
in diagrammatic or graphical way, well,
the objective time that we call the
spatial and linear cause relationship,
we say that one event causes the next
one, causes the next one, causes the
next one and so on. The the arrow is
very very clear. But in subjective time
we sort of have this, let's say
opportunity to well, flip one of the
arrows and say that well if I'm looking
at the event B not A and C but just the
event B. Well, the event B is
constituted by a retention and a
protention. So we have sort of flipped
the arrow here and these
are two very different orders of time as
we call them in our paper. One is
characterized by its unidirectional
development in time, which is the
objective one. The other one is
characterized by its bi directional
development in time and this is the
subjective one. Basically what we do oh
probably I should mention here that the
notation here is very important to sort
of get but we're always using the
SuperScript for the objective and the
subscript for the subject. I meant
objective, obviously the SuperScript for
objective and subscript of subjective
time dimensions and usually we use T
for the SuperScript and tau for the
subscript, just to be sure. So what we
propose in our paper is basically this
integrated continuity where we try to
combine both of them into a husserlin
interpretation. And obviously we're also
relying here a lot on conditional
dependencies here and this is from
statistics. I guess this is also why I
personally like to think of this as kind
of a tribute to Boltzman's statistical
approach to entropy, right? Because he
was the one who sort of took that step
away from simply thermodynamics
and movement between energy to thinking
about it more as statistics and
probability distributions. And I think
that was very fascinating. I think in
many ways this is kind of a tribute to
that, right, sort of taking the
boltsmonian way of thinking of it and
sort of adding this conditional
dependency layer to the development of
time.
This is what we sort of get at, right?
So if you look at the present moment B,
this is the event that we're trying to
understand. Well, there's a B minus one
in objective time but it's actually a
protention. So it's actually a plus one
as well because it was a plus. One
retention later for the next event,
which is C. And you can actually
generalize this the way we do at each
corner here. So Y, with the SuperScript,
the objective time plus minus K and the
subject of time plus minus ten, and you
can do the same for the other way, the
other direction. So basically
what we've been talking about so far is
talking about systems and whether
they're, how they function. And
especially I talked about the universe
functioning as kind of a closed system.
I think that's a huge assumption and I'm
not really buying into all of this, but
it's basically a good way to explain the
approaches that we have made. But the
body functions as an open system because
it's exchanging energy and information
all the time. And I'm preaching to the
choir here. You all know about markup
blankets and I don't think that it's
important to sort of introduce it to
this forum, but I would like to just
pinpoint a few things. The first one is
that I want to remind you that active
inference assumes that there's a border
between the central nervous system and
the environment and that can be
identified through a markup blanket.
And I also would like to emphasize the
fact that it's describing the processes
and dynamics rather than the things
themselves. And I'm really emphasizing
the process versus the thing because
Markov blanket okay, I'm all right,
so basically, Markov blanket, they
represent the statistical boundaries,
right, based on these conditional
relationships and they're typically
applied in the spatial domain. This is
my point. It's a statistical boundary in
the spatial domain. Also, I should
probably mention that when I talk about
conditional dependencies, because I
realized that there has been quite a lot
of debate about what we mean when we
talk about conditional dependencies.
Well, not specifically for our paper,
but in general, in statistical work,
what we mean here is that there is a
relationship between two or more events
that are dependent when a third
event occurs. This is basically the most
generic definition of conditional
dependencies, which you can find in
Judea Pearl's work on Markov and Beijing
networks. So my point here was
just to say that for the Markov blanket,
you see that it's just a statistical
boundary. And I know that Carl's
monograph, the famous monograph, sort of
takes that one step further and suggests
that, well, there are markup
blankets actually make up the physical
and the spatial boundary between things,
whereas the way that we apply this is
still in terms of statistics and
dynamics and processes. So we don't
really deal with that aspect here.
Should we really expect things this is
my point here. This is the question that
I'm asking. Should we really expect
things in active inference, which is a
process theory? I mean, I understand
that the spatial boundaries, they are a
matter of convenience, but can we really
expect them to sort of divide what
really is like the central nervous
system. When does it really transfer
into the actual flesh of the body?
These spatial transitions, they sort of
happen in degree and if we look at the
borderline, we will be looking at that
for ever and ever and we will look at
neurons and then atoms of neurons and so
on and so on. We will never be able to
really find a delineation. This is where
I think that the idea of temporal Markov
blanket sort of is a good idea. Just to
briefly sum this up, right? So Markov
blanket of this particular node is
constituted by its parents and its kids
and the parents of the kids here. So
anything that is around that will not
hold any valuable information about this
particular node. Again, I'm probably
preaching to the choir here, but here
I'm basically asking. So the
delineation is smart because it
gives us tractability, right? It makes
it tractable. We can start thinking
about the dynamics between things, but
in the context of time we might ask can
we apply the Markov blanket to the
temporal structure? Because we already
drew them as conditional dependencies.
So we sort of asked in our paper what
are the statistical boundaries of the
present moment? So I just show you this
one here before of the integrated
continuity drawn up here as a network of
conditional dependencies. So if I were
to sort of look at this particular
point, the event b,
well, we will find that if we try to map
out this Markov blanket, we will find
that, well, the information necessary to
understand this particular node is
actually constituted by a
bit of the present and sorry, a bit of
the past and a bit of the future.
Right? So basically we're kind of cheeky
doing this when I think about it because
we're sort of dressing the structure of
the blanket that happens in
time. And I think that obviously
how can I put this? This is
unconventional and which means that this
will have to be there will have to be
some limitations compared to the
conventional way you would use markup
blankets in spatial conditions, spatial
relationships. So first
we find that, well, all the information
needed to understand the present moment,
well, we find them to comply completely
with both principles of phenomenology.
We basically get the interpenetration of
past on the future and we also get this
integration between the objective and
the subjective time. So we get an
integration in this direction and we get
an integration in this direction here.
So that was actually our very first
surprise. So the second surprise when we
did this, it sort of occurred when we
tried to understand, to understand what
does it take to update the present
moment, right? And to actually propagate
the whole model through time. And for
that we need to analyze the update
function of a standard active inference.
PMDP yeah,
probably I should mention that the
conventional pmdps in robotics, they
don't use the same kind of update
function as we use it in active
inference because they are much more
explicit about the reward functions and
so on. And active inference obviously
cashes all of that out as free energy
minimization. So anyway, the dynamics of
the present moment are constituted by
two potentials. We have them up here and
a single retention which is down here.
And basically you will be able to get
this particular equation. And once we
start to sort of because these
are factors and if we sort of want to
turn that into sums, we need to convert
them to logarithms instead.
And basically if we just keep this one
in mind and put it over here, we see
that the first line is our derived model
from the slide before. And of course,
like anyone who's modeling, we have to
engage with this very central exercise
which I like to think about as providing
quality to quantity. I think this is a
very, very particular problem that
researchers in the field of
computational phenomenology have to deal
with as well. So keeping this exercise
in mind, because I will have some
comments about this towards the end.
So we have the hidden potential at T
plus one and the hidden primal
impression at T and T plus one,
basically what you see here. And then we
have the observed retention at T minus
one. This is basically what we derived
from our model from before. Now,
the second line here is basically the
update function of the active inference
pump DP. And once we actually just strip
it away from all its action
policies you noticed here there are no
action policies in this update. I will
return to why we did that. Then
basically what you have is the well,
it's pretty straightforward actually.
You have the prior, which is the forward
message passing and you have the
predictive, which is the backward one,
and you have the likely outcome.
So our notation here with the double
timeline, the double dimension of time
in the single notation sort of allows us
to understand better what is actually
going on here if we map the phonological
version or equation that we derived onto
the existing update function.
So I've omitted here a few equations
that if you're interested, you can find
them all in the paper. But essentially,
once it's all mapped out, it appears as
if the update function can be translated
into kind of a prior protention, a
predictive primal impression and a
likely retention. So very similar to how
protention was brought backward, the
retention here is brought forward in
time, linked with the likelihood and the
hidden state. So the discovery,
or surprise, I should rena say, is both
that the model appealed to the same
temporal structure as the active
inference model, although in a different
way.
So I just took this quote
from our paper because this is how we
sort of reason about it that this gives
rise to an integrated structure of time
where the past depends on prior
predictions and the future of my likely
retention, which speaks to the
phonological understanding of
experience. So just as in the hospital
analysis that retention, primal
impression and protension jointly make
up the living present, then we refer to
the set of inferences presented here as
the living inferences, which is sort of
a workplace here between Prestonian
and Husserlian formalities. So since
they are jointly, they serve together
sorry, since jointly they serve to
describe within an active inference
model the phonological process that give
rise to the living present.
So this is basically me working my way
here to the end. We don't have the
answer here. I still think that this is
very clear, but we have a suggestion for
an answer, which is the continuity that
we experience is due to the
interpenetration and synthesis of an
objective and subjective temporal
dimension. So yes, can we extract
principles? That was basically our
answer here. How does the continuous
flow in human experience emerge? Well,
through the interpenetration and
synthesis of two temporal dimensions,
can we extract principles from her
surian temporality? Yes, we can easily
extract principles from her surveillance
phenomenology. We just need to note
under what conditions this is done. And
I think this is an important note
because you remember when I said that
there is this quality to quantity
exercise that we all have to engage in.
So basically, my view is that
computational phenomenology, if it wants
to contribute to science, this will be
an extremely important exercise for when
and how quality is attributed to a
specific quantity. It needs to be
extensively and very clearly elaborated
argumentation. You can ask
why does this particular parameter here,
right, like typically in active
inference, there will be the
temperature. You say that, oh, this
particular parameter represents
attention. Well, does it behave like
attention and to what extent? Because it
will have a limit and we just need to
know when is that limit? Basically, in
our case, we saw that the temporality
can be modeled, but we need to know
under what circumstances. So in our
case, we assume that the present moment
is not a static, frozen moment in time,
just like space, but it endures.
There's a duration, right? And it's
essentially this insight that allows us
to create such an integration between
the two temporal dimensions. So finally,
I like to think that we demonstrated the
potential of active inference in being
used as a point of departure to model
basically the flow of subjective
experience. But I think that we have yet
to begin analyzing anything beyond that.
We basically need to start thinking
about including action policies. So
that's motion and ActInf and of course,
essentially we would arrive at something
that looks like content, right? So I
guess this is, in a way, our rigorous
approach and a humble start with
the very basics. And I think that this
very slow approach is exactly how it
should be because we should be cautious
about this relationship between
phenomenology and computational
modeling. Just a few words here about
our future work and what we were working
on. Now,
actually, this is an example of one
of the things that we are working on. I
will say that right now we are focusing
on another perspective of
our work which has to do with the direct
integration of motor, intentionality and
action. But basically in this particular
project, we're sort of trying to map out
the exact, let's say, structure of
time in any computational model, right?
Because when you analyze the update
function of any computational model, it
will reveal its temporal structure.
Like how does it bring the past into the
future, into this propagation for time?
So we could ask what about CNNs
convolutional neural networks? What
about recurrent neural networks or auto
encoders or all the other kinds of
algorithms? How do they function? Like,
how do they update their function? And I
think that by analyzing all of these
different algorithms and their update
function, we could sort of map out all
of these temporal structures and
understand better how they are
propagating in
space through time. So this would be, I
think, my last slide here. Yes, thank
you for your attention. That was much
longer than I sorry about that.
Was I muted the whole time longer. In
time or what exactly do you dean by
that? Well, I would say subjective
the time was very short. Objective time
was much longer. Thank you
both for this really excellent,
excellent dyad of presentations.
And I will pass first to Dean
or Ali. Whoever would like to just jump
in with a first thought or reflection,
please feel free. Go ahead, Ali.
Well, thank you so much for your amazing
presentation. Gosh, I have so many
comments and questions to ask. I don't
know where to begin. But you
see, because I'm also deeply interested
in process philosophy as well. It's not
necessarily the Whiteheadian process
philosophy, but generally thinking in
terms of flows and flocks and so on, as
opposed to substance and stasis.
But in my view,
well, historian phenomenology,
these conceptions of flows and the
temporality and retention, retention and
so on is a step toward
kind of process thinking, right? But
ultimately, I believe that Husserlian
philosophy, or more precisely,
historian phenomenology, fails to escape
the trap of substance thinking.
Because, you see, if I read
a direct quote from Husserl himself, he
says that time is like a flow but with
divisions. In other words, not like a
flow at all and in fact the opposite of
a flow. So the
reason he doesn't bestow this
kind of primacy to the temporality or
continuity is because obviously it
results in action prediction. In other
words,
if time is what constitutes object in
time, obviously that cannot itself be an
object in time. So he needs a more
primary way or more primary
concept to account for that kind of
division in temporality, namely the
absolute flu. But, well,
there are some arguments regarding
whether we can escape this apparent
or real contradiction or not,
which I'm not going into detail, but one
point I wanted to make is that if we
also try to bestow this
kind of primacy to the absolute
flow or Husserlian. Absolute flow?
Don't you think? We basically contradict
our initial aim to escape that
kind of substance
thinking? Given this contradiction that
arises? That's one of my question. The
other ones is about
the conception of objective time and
subjective time. So interestingly
well, you also began your discussion of
usurlean phenomenology with Hussarl's
famous musical example. And it's very
interesting that probably the most
influential music theory of the past 100
years, namely the Shankarian theory,
is fundamentally a phenomenological
theory because he
tries to theorize how we perceive each
moment in music as a culmination
of every bits of music we've heard so
far until that point.
And on the other hand, the anticipation
of what is to come and the other. So
each point of music is a kind of
combination of all the elements of
retention,
primal moment and also the pretension.
But there are some criticisms
put forward, especially by
Gerald Levinson regarding the
feasibility of this kind of description
because of our limited capacity of our
short term and working memory in trying
to at least consciously grasp all of the
details of the past and also our
limited capacity to predict every
possible future or every anticipation
from that single point. So my question
is, and also there is
another criticism regarding the the
ignoring the elasticity
of perceived time in Shankarian theory
and also in Husserlian phenomenology.
So my question is how would you account
for this kind of apparent elasticity
that all of us experience in the
subjective or manifest time?
And my very last question, sorry it took
me so long. My very last question is
about the objective time, which is do
you have any particular justification or
any particular reason for choosing one
among many of the physical theories of
objective time? So, for instance, we
have view from quantum gravity,
view from relativity, which basically
can be seen as kind of contradictory
because in general relativity we
allow for the time for temporality to be
fundamental. But in quantum gravity,
temporality is a kind of emergent
property that emerges from
Duit Wheeler equation. So is there
a specific reason that you
decided to choose Carlo Rovelli's
conception of objective time?
Again, apologies for my long winded
question. I'm looking forward.
Did I stop sharing my screen?
Probably it would be better so we. Can
see each other. Will you start? I think
some of the first questions were about
the ephemology. I have a few comments to
that and I think that if I may yeah, go
ahead. I also have some comments,
but go ahead. Yeah, so I would like to
just start by making the distinction
between time perception and temporality
in phenomenology. Because temporality
is more basic than time perception.
Time perception is actually a skill.
It's actually something like it's sort
of like attention and memory and so on.
It's a skill set we have and it's
something that we are performing. Some
are good at it, some are very bad, like
me. But in any case,
temporality and phenomenology talks not
about how your skills about time
perception. It's more about the actual
unfolding of anything. Like any
experience whatsoever. Like me now
shaping these thoughts to sort of convey
them. I'm not thinking about time
perception. I'm actually happening. And
there's like this unfolding of time
constantly, this continuous flow,
right? Whenever I talk about it, I like
to think about Lee smallen's reality of
time. I think that there is some truth
to his way of reasoning about time. The
fact that it's real and it's actually
more real than space. And space is
actually the emergent property of time.
That's actually, by the way, from
category theory and geometry theory as
well. That's where that comes from.
Because if you think about it like that,
if you think about the time being, the
thing that sort of pushes us forward,
right there's like this action, I would
even say that it's an involuntary
action. Like you're constantly doing
this, it's constantly happening. So for
me, I would make a clear distinction
between time perception and temporality.
Now, if I just jump directly to the end
of the question because I love to deal
with you ask why did we go with
calorovelli's thermodynamic arrow of
time? There is a good reason for that.
Because in the beginning, I believe we
discussed briefly the wheel of divit
equations. Because in that equation you
completely take away time, right? You
just say, well, basically you can
explain any kind of dynamics and change
without any variable of time. You just
need spatial parameters. I personally
think that that's great, that shows that
math works. Doesn't mean that that's how
it works. To me, the way that I think
about it is more about so it
doesn't matter what I think about it.
Why do we go with thermodynamic color of
endothermodynamic approach? Because he
starts with entropy. And that sort of
builds perfectly well on our approach
and our analysis of active inference
being built on entropy being, however,
another kind of entropy. It still builds
on the very same, let's say ontology,
right? It's built on the same idea and
it fits. That idea could still be wrong.
In any case, if you go with David and
Wheeler's equations, you still have
another dimension of time that is
different from the subjective one. I
think I should be clear here that I'm
not saying that they exist
independently. I'm just saying that it's
two different things and we can think
about them individually. And there is an
advantage in doing something like that
because then you can start looking at
how they integrate afterwards. So this
is merely convenience, right? There is
no such thing as only a subjective time
without objective time. And the other
way around, this is not part of the
paper. It's way beyond the scope of the
paper. Anyway.
Yeah, kind of lashing into Sack's
comment towards the end is that when we
were writing the paper, we're discussing
slightly about how we should address
objective time. And in the end we
decided to use calorie by this framework
as sax, as just a matter of convenience.
I think at least I'm very much an
instrumentalist in that sense, that you
can have a lot of different stories of
how physical time works, and that's
important and that's okay. But in the
end, I don't think that affects much our
overall purpose, which is to say there's
an integration between an objective
sense of time, take calorie, take
quantum physics, et cetera, and
subjectivity in which we are pretty much
committed to the Husserlin framework.
Which this brings me to the other two
questions concerning the first one about
kind of the relationship between process
ontology and husserlin phenomenology. I
think the important thing to note here,
and this is my interpretation, to be
honest, is that when we talk about
consciousness and time, consciousness
and the absolute flow within the
Husserlin framework, it's important to
notice that it is not a thing. And I
think it's also an important thing to
keep in mind when we address how are we
to explain consciousness scientifically.
I do believe that a sort of implicit
assumption within a lot of the
literature, especially the earlier one,
is to assume that consciousness,
insofar as a phenomenon, it's also a
thing that has to arise from, say,
neural processes or neurophysiological
processes or whatever kind of frame
you're subscribing to, but it's not
really that. And that's the nice thing
about phenomenologists, especially in
phenomenology, is that when you go to
the kind of the deep level of whatever
is happening subjectively, you won't
find a thing. You find what he calls the
absolute flow, which does sound like a
thing as a river. And he does say that
it's a flow, but it's not. There's
always this hesitation in the literature
because he notices that
everything in flow, what we experience,
there's a lot of stuff happening at the
same time and in time, but it kind of
keeps an structure which is retention,
primal impression and protention. So
there's this kind of paradoxical nature
to the absolute flow. It's pure flow,
but it has a specific structure. But
when you look at how that structure
functions and that's kind of the step
that he takes from what the so called
static to the genetic or dynamical
phenomenology is that this structure is
just a set of processes that are always
happening, not things. It's not that
retention is a thing, but no, it's
literally processes, happening,
synthesis, as he calls it. And that's
what we think it's interesting to
connect to the ActInf inference
framework or any other modeling
framework, is that then you don't really
have to capture a thing, say quality as
the redness of the red, but actually
you're just trying to capture processes
with processes. So you have retention
and you have inferences that's it you
don't have really things, you have stuff
that is happening through time and you
don't really have to commit to any sort
of object ontology. You have just
processes moving on through which
something more stable arises. But it's
not a thing. Once again, when we
experience, say, the bottle, it's a
thing, but it's always given itself in
time. It's always changing. I can see
its movement. I can move around all its
time. That's the nice thing about it.
And concerning the other question,
which was the one and the limitations on
working. Memory, how's the elasticity of
time perception. Can you elaborate more
about the concepts of elasticity as you
were using it? Sure. You see
the familiar phenomena that we
experience when we somehow experience
this speeding up or slowing down the
experience or living present. That's
basically what I mean by elasticity of
time perception. Brilliant.
I often wonder because certainly when we
talk about subjective temporality in the
husserlin sense, that's not really what
he's trying to capture. That's quite
clear. When he talks about structure of
time conscious, he's very explicit.
We're talking about formal structure
that remains arguably invariant through
all experiences. But it's true that
there's a sort of flexibility to how to
experience the world. And this is
literally a speculation for me. I'd have
to sit down and think more about it.
But I think there's an important
connection between affectivity and
temporality here. So especially
in activism, there's this discussions
about how affectivity and time conscious
in the Australian or Penometrical sense
link to one another. For example, this
is not an activism disclosure. Matthew
Ratcliffe talks about styles of
anticipation. We may anticipate
something with anxiety or with hope or
with fear, and that probably stretches
out not only that we anticipate, but how
we anticipate. And that's very important
distinction between how we anticipate
something and what we're anticipating
something. And this also kind of
constitutes our general openness to the
world because, say, I'm sitting down
completely bored, waiting for something,
not only the experience of time kind of
stretches out, but also there's a
special kind of effective atmosphere to
our world. But once again, this kind of
opens up another question about for
computational neurophenomenology, which
is, okay, now we have inactive
inference, this kind of clear cut
temporal structure that links up to
cocellant phenomenology. How can we
introduce effectivity into the picture?
And there's of course a lot of work and
effectivity emotions athlete more
generally in the active inference
framework. But that's an interesting
question. How does it relate to our
temporal model? I don't know if Zach has
anything else to add? I was just
reminded of a few things there. I think
you're totally on point with everything
you said. I just want to emphasize the
fact that the stretch and the plasticity
of time is still, in my opinion,
something of a skill that we have.
Right? It's an impression. And that
impression is something that we get at.
And just because I have that experience
doesn't mean if I had, like, a twin and
we were doing this not even just a
friend, and we were doing the exact same
thing, that stretch will be very
individual. And that just means that it
depends on who you are and your skill at
doing that. I cannot really
differentiate between time perception
and the plasticity that sort of is
implicit in time perception. I cannot
distinguish that from other skills,
like being able to remember something or
directing your attention at something
because that's exactly the same thing.
We don't have the same skill. Like,
some people are very bad at suppressing
peripheral information, others are not.
And it just continues like that.
But I do have a point.
So do you guys know James Terrell, the
light designer? Artist, american artist?
He's a fantastic light designer. I
highly recommend you go see all of his
work. Basically, he studied the
eye and vision. So he's not a vision
neuroscientist, but he studied vision
for many, many years. And he's a light
designer. And basically he creates these
huge installations everywhere. And one
that really caught my attention was in
Japan, I think now it's seven years ago,
where we went into this pitch dark room,
right? It's a big temple that was
reconstructed. Pitch dark, couldn't see
anything. And you just had to touch the
wall. And you had to follow the wall.
And then suddenly you feel like, okay,
now there are other people also holding
the wall. And you sort of feel other
people. You go, okay, I need to stop. I
shouldn't follow the wall anymore. And
at some point, you're just staring out
in complete darkness. The space suddenly
emerges. Your eyes adjust to the very,
very low light. Well, the lux I don't
know the exact illuminance. I suppose in
English, the very low illuminance, you
start to adjust. And this can only
happen over time. I think that this sort
of is an example of temporality,
sensory impression content. I wouldn't
say quality, because I don't buy into
that.
I'm more of a time person. I don't know
if you get the impression. But I have a
question for you as well, Ellie, if I
may, because this example that I just
gave here with James Terrell and I'm an
architect myself, usually I give that
example with the spaces.
Would you say that it's the same
experience or would you say that those
are two very different experiences?
Well, certainly there are similarities
between those two experiences. I'm not
sure if they're identical or even they
can be. Discussed,
I don't know in the same terms,
but going back to your
point on the temporality and also the
skill, the discrepancy between the
primacy of the temporality versus the
scale of time perception, I certainly
agree with you on that. But I also
believe that, you see,
I don't think, at least in my opinion,
that temporality or the absolute flow,
or at least historically an absolute
flow, is the most fundamental
concept that needs to be grounded
because there needs to be even
more fundamental prior to even existence
of that temporality or that flow.
Right? Which I'm not going into details
about how that fundamentality can
be accounted for or it can even be
discussed in terms of our
observed phenomena or our experience
phenomena. But I wanted to thank both of
you for your extensive response you
provided and helpful responses. I wanted
to ask for your permission to
I wanted to discuss these matters a bit
further with you. So if you permit, I
wanted to email you about them and
discuss them a bit further because
that's something that I'm deeply
interested in. So, again, thank you so
much. Thank you. Of course. Thank you.
Can I say something before we go? Just a
small thing, because Ali just mentioned
this that he doesn't think that the
balls is kind of the basic thing. And I
don't know to what extent I agree. But
something I do think that happens is
that at least in the Whosolian
framework, this kind of conception,
that consciousness or subjectivity more
generally is this kind of layered or
hierarchical structure of which you have
to find literally the basis and go from
the ground up, so to speak. And I think
there's something true to that, but it's
not as hierarchical as Wishful would put
it. Because once again, this brings us
back to the concept, this relationship
between affectivity and temporality.
For me, I would say affectivity informs
temporality, and temporality informs
affectivity are co emergent. But how can
you affect it? Because you have a body
and then you introduce embodiment into
the picture. And if you introduce
embodiment to the picture, you open up a
lot of like you open up the Pandora's
box almost. So maybe this whole idea of
the most basic stuff, it's a bit of a
red herring. But I also think there's
something valuable and Husserl would
agree on this bit, is that temporality
is very abstract. It's just a formal
structure which underpins all
experience, regardless of whether it's
the most basic structure or not. That's
a different question. And that's all I
wanted to say for now. Awesome. All
right, we'll pause
in time and move on.
Dean, please. Where does this take you?
Well, I'm like Ally a whole bunch of
places. I'm not like Ally in the sense
that I do place a very high priority and
emphasis on timing and
perspectives. That doesn't mean that
Allie and I don't get along
fantastically. We do it's just that it's
that different perspective thing that I
think gives this whole topic a certain
richness. I want to touch for a second
on Zach's teasing
out the word skills because I think
that's really important here. My
background is sort of in the practical
aspects of learning. So I tend
to zoom out on not just the particulars,
but the whole picture. And I want to
just say before I ask my question is
I thought it was a fantastic comparative
analysis in your paper and I thought
your presentation and your sharings
today were also very clear in terms of
being able to show difference and same,
which I think only comes about when we
account for the temporality. I'm not
saying measure it, but at least have a
certain appreciation of it. So here's my
thing practicalities. In other
words, the actions in active inference
are not necessarily always a capture.
That could be one form of an action,
but it's not the only one. There are
plays, there are creations and
compositions which we looking at
category theory are quite intimately
familiar with now. So one
of the things that I tried to bring to
the conversation about a decade ago,
I was working with a number of people in
complexity science and complexity
research and they were huge maturana and
Varella fans. And for about two years
all I did was have conversations like
the one we're having today with
complexity scientists. And one of the
things I tried to bring to them in terms
of understanding the possibility of
applying skills as learning were
number one.
You first have to be able to get people
to pay some sort of attention, have an
awareness of what they
are embedded in, what their niche is,
what is being signaled to them, et
cetera. Number two, you have to be able
to link and combine. And I know that in
a lot of formal learning settings, that
association piece, that skill of being
able to do that sort of compare and is
this same, is this different? Again,
category theory stuff, there's a heavy
emphasis placed on that. Then there's
another skill which is to be able to set
a rule, to be able to scale up around
what is consistent, what is seeming,
to be able to have a certain shelf life
and things that are changing rapidly,
because you guys talked a lot about
change today. So that's basically an
understanding. You can know in English
where that came from. You're basically
standing under the abstracted state,
the heuristics, the little sort of rules
of thumb that you apply as a skill
subjectively. And then finally, and this
is one that's left off of most
conversations, there's a particular type
of self organ. All of these are self
organizations. Even if you're being
prompted by the teacher, you still have
to take up the skill of organizing
yourself. But there's a fourth type of
skill, which is a particular type of
self organization, which is being the
capacity to transfer recapitulate in a
timely manner. And I think that's where
your paper is opening up a bit of a
Pandora's box. It's not just a
comparison of objective and subjective
time. It's how do we know when
to reapply the rule? And I think from
a learning standpoint, that's a
big moment. It's not just a Eureka
moment, but it's a sense of do my
inferences now
withstand the scrutiny of the
environment? The environment generally,
not just the niche. So is the niche
capturing us, or are we still free to
think about how that next move fits
with all the prior moves? And I think
that requires the representation that
you guys had in your paper, that
essential diagonal line. And so I
think that's what you did, I think what
you've touched on it and put into
defendable form is, okay, so there's all
these skills, and do we cut ourselves
off at the more phenomenological
ones? Are you paying attention? Are you
making associations? Or are you freeing
yourself up to be able to have these
rules, but then know when to repurpose
them as the context changes? So I
want to applaud you because I've had
many, many conversations for over a
decade where there's a whole bunch of
people who do not want to talk about the
third and the fourth skill because it's
hard to measure, but I think you guys
have brought some ability to compose
that. And so that's all I wanted to say.
I don't have any questions. Just want to
give you two claps.
Thank you very much. Thanks a lot.
I don't even know what to say because I
guess to Juan Diego and I,
it was actually, I think, over a Twitter
conversation, we sort of realized a few
things and basically linked up and
started working on this. And apparently
we have a lot in common in terms of
philosophy. Well, and also other things.
But interestingly, we found out that
there was actually a plausible
attractable relationship that we could
exploit, so well,
thanks a lot. I'm very happy to
see that there's someone else who is
also like a very temporal person,
right? Like thinking about things and
time and events rather than things. And
I think this is a very important
distinction. Yeah, for sure. Thank you
for that comment, Dean. And I also think
that it kind of speaks to the whole
temporal thing we're talking about
precisely because what we learn, we
learn through time. And that's kind of
obvious, but you have to kind of address
how this temporality works in order to
eventually talk about learning and
following rules and being understanding
our environment. You were saying kind of
understanding how to apply these rules
and how to apply different skills in a
proper environment, adaptively, so to
speak. And something that first kind of
attracted me to the active inference and
FEP context was the possibility of
making sense of how, through updates to
generative models, you can try to make
sense formally of these skills and these
process that underline what it's like to
be an organism and a human being in a
changing world. And once again, it
brings us back to change temporality.
All this stuff, it's all connected.
Can I just do one quick follow up,
Daniel? Because I know I want to make
sure you have some time as well. I think
what people struggle with is they can
name it and call it transference.
And oftentimes that gets conflated with
understanding and wisdom, and that isn't
necessarily so. That timely way of
being able to recapitulate something is
an incredibly important skill. If we get
that wrong, we oftentimes materially
fall off a cliff. But whether or not we
can see it as both discretized as its
own entity, its own particulars,
and part of this massive hole that
requires all of these priors as well,
being able to juggle that,
I think, is, again, that's what you've
opened up here. And hopefully people
are able to then take that information
and test it, because that's the best
thing to do. In fact, this morning, in
another separate conversation
altogether, I was asked how to
take some of the practicalities and the
skills that you guys talked about in
your paper and apply them in real time.
And it's not really, really hard if you
have at least those four skills. It is
very difficult if you stop at the
associative level or if you stop at the
I built a rule now, and I know how far
that rule will extend. So that's my
final say for today. Go ahead. Sorry,
Daniel. Oh, it's all great.
So many threads weaving together. So,
again, to both presenters and authors,
it was excellent. The dominant
sense or impression is that it's
very evocative, what you've presented.
The idea of a generative passage. Not
just does it touch upon generative
models, generative AI, but also this
idea that our travels are generative.
Like, whenever we see a friend and we
take the train, we always have some
story to share and like something that
happened along the way. I know that's
not necessarily how it's used, but it's
just what it evoked. When you describe
formal, dynamical models as generative
passages, it's not 95 theses to pin
onto the door. It's something that
evokes. And you even spoke about taking
different perspectives on your work
rather than your work advancing a
perspective. And then to hear about the
connections with the light and sound art
and visual art and the
notion of architecture and your
background. Zach and the interplay
between space and time and the way that
sometimes we can look at a blueprint and
see it as static, or even the
constructed, embodied building as a
static object when it also moves through
time. Then one more impression
and then a question. Finally,
the vocabulary and the
delicacy of the articulation with the
protention retention and the primal
impression or the living presence. And
then the way in which graphically you
arranged it along orthogonal axes
like rows and columns that allowed us to
slide through on the diagonal.
It gives a lot to work with.
And my question is where is the action
perception loop? Or how do you believe
that this time consciousness and
associated methods and skills?
How can we then go back to potentially
earlier or contemporary representations
of the particular partition under the
FEP or just the active inference action
perception loop? How can we see that or
be with that differently with the
advances that are happening literally in
the last year in this area?
Oh, man, that's right on. I mean,
spot on. This is exactly the kind of
research I do. Basically, I have like,
I guess, two paths in my research. I
think 80% of my time is empirical
research, doing neuroscience and
basically doing experiments all the
time. And one way that I translate all
of this, all of these insights that I
get from working with someone like Juan
Diego is to try to understand them as
what I like to think about as sensory
motor entropy. Basically talking about
it as the interaction and the loop that
naturally occurs not only in action
perception, but also in past and
present. And if I may just briefly share
my screen again, I would like to show
you that this last aspect, I think I
hope you can see my arrow. I'm not sure
I'm just going to take the laser pointer
just to be sure that this last point
here, I think this sort of maybe over
here it's better. You can see that the
retention and the protension sort of
correlating or sort of meeting
here in the middle and sort of creating
a loop through time. So if we have to
jump from this point, this is the update
step some from updates that one to two.
You sort of need to create this
interwoven link between them. This is
naturally creating a loop between,
well, action and perception because
action what brings you forward in time
perception was part of the retention.
And basically there will be this
naturally occurring loop just from basic
principles of temporality. It's like you
cannot get around that ActInf.
Perception sort of emerges from
temporality all naturally. So in my
opinion, the way that I think about it
is as sensory motor entropy. And
basically you can look at that and the
amazing results that people are finding
now around the thalamus, which is
basically the central organ of the
brain, the subcortical structure
actually functions as a bridge between
major brain regions, right? So for you
to actually perform any kind of ActInf,
it needs to use the thalamus as a
bridge, which means that it's
intrinsically related to the way things
change. And there's like this, I guess
you can think about it not as things,
but as events, right? So to give an
example like Juan Diego did with his
bottle. This is my cup. And the fact
that my cup continuously exists is not
the thing that exists all the time, but
there are events occurring in which this
one continues to exist. Right. So it's
more about thinking of the evolution of
time being highly correlated with itself
rather than thinking about things
existing in time. But this is like a
reverse way of thinking about it. And
the typical strategy of active inference
is flipping things on the head and see
if it actually still makes sense. In
this case, I genuinely think it does. I
don't know if I answered your question.
Yes. Thank you, Dean.
Yeah. Just to be able to hold up two
things again, I would say that there is
the Bridging piece and there is also the
high occupancy vehicle lane as opposed
to the intersection. Like a lot of the
ways that we represent this stuff is
when we get those X and Y vectors
crossing one another. But there's also
let's get all four skills onto
one platform and remove a lot of the
impediments. And that's that flipping
part. I would agree exactly with what
you're saying. You have to have both one
as a metaphor. That's all it is,
metaphorical. But if you can get all
four skills in one place and then
down the distance, you'll shorten the
amount of time it takes to arrive at
wherever you're going.
Thank you, Juan. And please feel
free to give kind of your closing
thoughts and next angles as we come
near. I don't even know whether to call
it an ends.
Lovely. So I just wanted to go back to
Daniel's question because I thought was
a great question, one I didn't think
about, at least in the specific terms,
which Zach, we've been discussing
precisely, kind of where action fits
in all the story. And this, of course,
brings us to the action perception loop.
And I guess I'm going to do what we
usually do in our collaborations with
Zack, which is album the Phenomenology
and see whether it fits. And I think it
fits quite well because what we did in
our model is to show that precisely this
boundary, this temporal boundary to the
updating scheme of active inference
which integrates past and future. And we
kind of relate this to protention,
retention, primal attraction, and you
have this nice living present. What is
fascinating is that when you go a step
further away from the pure temporal form
of experience, you have an embodied
being whose anticipations, whose
protentions are not simply the tones
that are coming from the melody, but
what do you do with them or what do you
do? So if I see my bottle again, this
bottle appears as something I can grasp.
And you can think about this in terms of
importances, action possibilities.
That's very clear in the
phenomenological literature. And also,
I think, in the active inference
literature, when you talk about action
policies and specific importances, all
this stuff, it is fascinating because
then you get action just by introducing
the temporal aspect of active inference.
But this action is always informed by
prior observation, so by literally
perception. And that happens as well in
phenomenology. All our actions are
informed, but what we are seeing, what
we're perceiving more generally and what
we've perceived in the past, and you can
just kind of unfold that loop and get a
very nice correlation between action and
perception through time. So the action
perception loop is not like this
monolithic circle. It's something that
it's more like in a spiral, so to speak.
And I think our model speaks to that.
I don't know if Zach wants to add
anything to this.
It really would make worlds of
difference to call it an action
perception spiral. If it's just going to
be a visual metaphor and rely on our
cultural understandings of shapes,
why not firstly, hold up multiple
and then secondly, bring in this
kind of perhaps even double helical or
triple helical nature of unfolding.
And three makes a party. So it's
awesome. Ollie and Dean,
first, any closing thoughts?
And then the authors with the final
words. I'll be really quick. I really
want to thank you both for sharing the
paper and the great presentation.
Thank you, Dean. Ali. Yeah, as I said,
it was a really fascinating paper for me
personally because I was really obsessed
with process thinking, processual and
all kinds of dynamic thinking. So,
again, I really wanted to thank you for
writing such an amazing paper. Yeah,
thank you so much.
Awesome. And so, to the authors,
any closing thoughts or where you'll be
heading now, or what you're excited,
what you're protending?
I guess, first of all, I would just like
to thank you because this has been an
amazing experience, an experience,
temple experience, actually, just to
discuss our paper with you. Thank you
for reading the paper. Thank you for
enjoying the paper and having us. It's
been lovely. And I think it's quite
clear that the way to go now is to start
talking about action and see how it
fits. And hopefully sooner rather than
later you'll see something about this,
because it's precisely what we're
discussing with Zach more recently.
Yeah, I also would like to extend this.
Thank you. It's fantastic.
The whole active active inference
institute, just, in my opinion, the
right thing is really amazing to follow.
So I'm very happy to be part of this.
Besides the active aspect of hopefully
the next paper, I'm also looking
into phases and looking at active
inference as if it did not work with
states, because I think that's too
spatial and it's making things static.
But actually moving that into phases,
into a continuous space is something
that I'm trying to establish now,
trying to start up a collaboration with
Ryan Smith about that. But it's still a
really early work in progress, so
hopefully we'll see something from that
project in a few months time.
Hopefully. But thanks again. Thank you.
Awesome. Thank you all for joining.
Thanks, everybody, for listening, and
you're always welcome back. So till the
next time.
Bye. Thank you.